bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro d'
envies de lecture avec noter les vols
font déjà positivement ravi de vous
retrouver non ben oui ça faisait un
petit moment ravi masqué est ravi vous
êtes masqué mais vous êtes là quand même
et puis en plus on va parler on va
parler de rencontre on va parler d'amour
par les deux couples avec caroline faye
bonjour bonjour
pour votre roman jules et judy histoire
double paru chez anne carrière alors
pour vous présenter très vite vous êtes
à la fois psychologues et psychanalystes
dont vous recevez beaucoup de gens au
suppose qu'en plus tôt quand ça va mal
dans le couple un trait plutôt 50 quand
ça va mal et quand on s'interroge ou au
début effectivement d'une relation au
début de droit est au début d'une
relation et puis il arrive aussi que des
patients que je suis au régulièrement
d'un seul coup rencontre avec donc voilà
forcément il m'en font part on en parle
ça c'est votre métier puis vous avez été
aussi vous avez animé une émission sur
europe 1 nous mettions 2d libre on
t'aime où il y avait beaucoup de
témoignages vous avez été chroniqueuse
dans une émission sur france bourse de
qui s'appelait je t'aime et s'est
présentée par daphné bürki dans lesquels
évidemment il ya le sens du grand public
faut savoir expliquer je pense que tout
ça a fait que vous avez eu envie
d'écrire ce roman c'est à dire que je
trouve que quelquefois quand on est
psychologue et psychanalyste
on part dans des hauteurs
stratosphériques pour expliquer des
choses très simples du quotidien et
voilà j'avais une grande envie de
simplicité je trouve que dieu et le
diable se cache dans les détails
c'est pour ça que j'ai donné beaucoup de
détails dans son livre parce que ce sont
les détails qui sont importants et que
ce sont les détails qui alimente le
quotidien et que c'est une façon aussi
pour le lecteur les lectrices de
s'identifier aux personnages que j'ai
mise en scène lors d'ateliers au peuple
eh bien on y va de ses vrais mots furent
ravis parce que l'écriture et
psychanalyse j'adore et ça fait forcer
outre atlantique a aussi à irvin yalom
des écrivains comme ça qu'ils ont même
psychanalyser
des personnages historiques post mortem
à nietzsche le docteur brewer qui était
le mentor de freud enfin bon alors tout
ça c'est passionnant on va revenir au
roman qui on va pas le spo il est comme
on dit en bon français
mais comme je viens petit peut expliquer
de quoi il s'agit donc on a deux
quarantenaires julika qui à 39 ans jules
qui en a 42 alors chacun étaient mariés
chacun a été larguée et ils ont aussi
des enfants julien une petite fille et
puis jules a deux garçons et comme
énormément de gens de leur génération
ils vont s'adresser à des sites de
rencontres sur internet alors dans votre
roman c'est à tous coeurs et alors
peut-être avant d'aller plus loin deux
premières questions sur vos personnages
patrice l'a dit le roman s'appelle jules
et julie histoire double qu'on a des ici
des prénoms qui sont au menu main
presque double en quoi sont-ils double
et en quoi sont-ils singulier ou pour le
dire plus clairement est ce que les
réactions des femmes et des hommes sont
les mêmes face à une histoire d'amour et
bien pas toujours justement ça n'exclut
pas qu'on ne pense on ne puisse pas
avoir les mêmes sentiments les mêmes
afaq temps on est tous traversés par les
émotions la colère la tristesse
l'anxiété la peur c'est surtout
d'ailleurs sur les peurs que j'ai mis
l'accent dans ce livre mais disons que
histoire double parce que ce qui
m'intéressait c'était que la même
histoire soit vécue
simultanément par les deux personnages
et que chacun donne sa version de ce
qu'il était en train de vivre c'est à
dire qu'on a une alternance c'est de
penser chez cgc 2 0 chez ces deux
protagonistes chacun décrit tour à tour
ce que ça suscite en lui ce que ça
allait les émotions que ça déclenche les
réflexions peur cette alternance comme
sa valeur est faible et les réactions
que ça suscite et puis pour pouvoir
encore mieux débriefer j'ai choisi de
les faire aller chacun raconte leur
histoire ils ont chacun un 10o est
ridicule le récit de chacun et animaux
c'est par là par leur conversation avec
leur préséance non bien entendu c'est
pas dans la presse que sinon c'est très
compliqué à cet effet nous sommes
d'ailleurs j'ai des petits yeux nous
sommes j'ai voulu que ce soit comme ça
pour que tout le monde soit content
et j'espère qu'on sexuelle encore
disons que là j'ai choisi de faire
quelque chose où il y avait une vraie
expérience aussi bien du côté des héros
que du côté des psys parce que ça me
semblait intéressant même si les psys
sont censés penser de la même manière je
trouvais tout de même intéressant qu'un
psy soit une femme est comme ci soit un
homme moi ça m'a beaucoup intéressé
d'ailleurs les psys parce que c'est vrai
que
je connais pas forcément le mien le
niveau des primes j'ai l'impression qui
déculpabilise
ils ont tendance à déculpabiliser les
valeurs leurs patients quoi ah bah c'est
le but je veux dire quand on va chez soi
on est pris dans un étau de culpabilité
de culpabilité qui sont issus de
croyance qu'on s'est forgé depuis la
toute petite enfance c'est ça qui est
important il faut bien voir que
l'inconscient n'a pas d'âge on a quatre
ou cinq ans à 60 à 5 50 à 49 80 c on est
toujours en pro à des réactions qui sont
des réactions enfin quand il est enfant
soleil c'est à dire que toute la vie
psychique n'est qu'un combat contre
l'infantile 1 mais c'est très bien
d'ailleurs non mais c'est vrai que c'est
c'est très rassurant ses conversations
avec des petits gâteaux parce que
évidemment enfin on va reparler mais
comme comme nathalie ils sont ils sont
quand même modulée par leur part leur
propre échec 1 1 ils ont eu deux échecs
chacun donc ça leur pèse évident mais
c'est donc il se demande quand est ce
qu'ils vont pouvoir en groupe quand on
doit faire avec ce qu'on vous pour
réussir en gros ça c'est à dire qu'on
vit dans une société aussi où il ya une
sorte d'injonction au bonheur si vous
voulez avant on se mariait on n'avait
pas le choix de son partenaire il était
imposé je parle dans des temps mais le
mariage d'amour ou le choix de son de
son partenaire c'est très simple c'est
seulement
une centaine d'années quand un truc
voilà est ce qu'ils veulent d'abord
voilà c'est encore le rsa ou presque
mais maintenant qu'on a le choix
maintenant qu'on a le choix c'est à dire
que quand ça ne fonctionne pas on est en
on est en proie à ce sentiment d'échec
qui n'existait pas avant parce que comme
on n'avait pas choisi on se disait pas
ça a raté parce que j'ai été trop comme
si outre comme ça mais on parce que je
n'ai pas su faire ci ou je n'ai pas su
faire ce n'était pas notre faute
et du coup on n'était pas en proie à
cette écurie a ses petites manies voilà
mais maintenant c'est fait aujourd'hui
finalement qui exige une certaine
silhouette qui exige un certain nombre
de réactions une réussite vous parliez
de l'injonction au bonheur tout à
l'heure est ce que les réseaux sociaux
l'ont pas encore plus exacerbée alors
est comment c'est à dire que qu'est ce
qu'on met en scène sur les réseaux
sociaux soit vous avez
7,7 à cette tendance avec les body
on s'accepte etc mais sinon ce qu'on met
en scène c'est soi-même au mieux de soi
même c'est à dire qu' on cherche à
apparaître en permanence sous son
meilleur jour pour montrer à quel point
on est formidable intelligent et à quel
point aussi on a une vie extraordinaire
donc vous imaginez la pression quand on
regarde les images des rays sur les
réseaux sociaux de l'avis des autres
c'est à dire que ça c'est une vraie
pression qu'en soi même on est pas on se
trouve pas au top on cherche on se dis
pas tiens les autres eux aussi quand ils
se lèvent le matin ils sont pas tout à
fait ils sont pas tout à fait formidable
et c'est ça on l'oubli on attende quand
on va sur les réseaux sociaux enfin les
janvier ils ont tendance à laisser pas à
se vendre quand même améliorer l'offre
et le noyage ya cette tendance là non
c'est le parti vous parlez des photos
par exemple combien c'est important de
choix de la photo est important de choix
de la photo j'en parle surtout à propos
des sites de rencontres est-ce qui est
ce qui est flagrant d'ailleurs c'est que
la plupart du temps on a tendance à
choisir une photo qui date d'il ya dix
ans c'était voilà donc oui et que ça
c'est un mec aille je le dis pour ce
qu'ils m'ont dit oui parce que d'essayer
de nous parce que de toute façon quand
la rencontre va mieux vous n'aurez pas
échappé au constat de la réalité vous
allez voilà donc au saas est un petit
travers dans lequel il vaut mieux éviter
de tomber maintenant le poids des
réseaux sociaux il est dingue et y est
dingue parce que il faut voir aussi
qu'on est quand même la première société
civilisation à se rendre malheureux de
ne pas être heureux tout le temps oui
c'est ça c'est cool tu sais quoi il que
jeudi à rien une injonction au bonheur
quoi enfin alors que d'autres
civilisations savent que les épreuves
enfin et d'autres sociétés savent que
les épreuves la maladie la mort le deuil
les séparations font partie de la vie
nous sociétés occidentales on a un mal
fou à l'intégrer on éradique voilà on
est ravis on essaye d'éradiquer les
chèques comme l'échec des relations
amoureuses comme les com
certains moments douloureux dont la vie
or on oublie que c'est une alternance
est précisément ce que j'ai voulu
montrer dans ce livre c'est que n'est
pas tout le temps n'importe quoi c'est
pas le maintien n'est pas heureux tout
le temps qu'on n'est pas normal on peut
heureusement qu'on ne prend pas ce que
l'on saurait pas ce que c'est que d'être
heureuse nous
aider mais d'où le succès d'ailleurs de
tous et dit kiki qui disent qu'ils vont
vous apprendre à être heureux
tout à fait mais qui vont vous apprendre
à être heureux c'est à dire que bon
parce que ça s'apprend non moi je pense
que oui mais je pense que ça se met des
rails d'abord comme disaient les
aptitudes comme disent les philosophes
c'est vrai que l'on voit bien ce que
c'est le malheur pour le définir le
bonheur c'est beaucoup plus c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué à savoir ce que
c'est et ferait le bonheur ça n'existe
pas ou n'existe pas on a bien des
moments il ya le moment moi ce que
j'explique la plupart du temps et
patience et savourer ce qui est bon ça
vous donnera les ressources psychiques
pour affronter ce qu'il sera moins oui
et d'ailleurs quand on quand on lit
votre livre on et j'incite tous ceux qui
s'apprêtent à aller sur les wii mais aux
socios sur les 6 et 7 mai et si vous y
voilà si vous avez vous être sur les
réseaux sociaux lisez le livre ça va je
pense et on veut on voit ça ça sa
présence quand ce que vous disiez un
instant on veut quand même qu'il ya des
choses assez contraire c'est à dire que
d'un côté on est en plein dans l'open
bar on se connaît pas on se lie qu on se
rencontre et puis là une histoire
commencée puis à linverse
ccc jules et votre personnage l'un des
deux personnages principaux qui le dit
et que j'ai le site et j'ai beaucoup
aimé ce passage je me sens banal
interchangeables l'aïe qui pour des
raisons futiles zapper pour des motifs
qui le sont tout autant clic j'existe
clic je disparais alors y'a vraiment ce
sentiment de n'être que virtuelle et de
produits de consommation
mais oui mais ce que c'est un peu comme
ça que ça se passe sur les réseaux
sociaux on oublie qu en fait derrière la
photo qui est juste une image il y à
vraiment quelqu'un c'est à dire une
personne avec un passé une histoire un
vécu et puis qui est traversée par tout
un tas de l'affect et au fond quand on
cherche quelqu'un sur un sur les réseaux
sociaux qu'est-ce qui se passe on est on
coche des cases voilà c'est aussi est ce
qui m la campagne le feu de bois la
littérature
voilà et dans ce coup c'est comme si on
avait un catalogue de spécificités or
quand on va rencontrer quelqu'un on a on
n'a pas un catalogue on a devant soi une
personne et c'était ça que je veux
mystère qui veut bluewin.ch bourse afin
qu'en dehors des réseaux sociaux un bébé
mais la réalité elle est bien là c'est à
dire qu'ils jouent je sais pas j'ai pas
de chiffres en tête mais je crois qu'il
ya de plus en plus de gens qui se
rencontrent avec les cédants contrebasse
devenu
maire banal de se rencontrer parce
qu'avant vous aviez quoi on a vraiment
beaucoup plus rural il y avait le bal du
14 juillet les balles rouleau le haut
disons que le boulot pas seulement on
connaissait beaucoup ses voisins sa rue
le quartier je veux dire il y avait une
plus grande proximité aujourd'hui on n'a
jamais été aussi connecté on n'a jamais
été aussi seul donc on est en proie à
une forme d'isolement
même dans le travail vous avez des gens
qui dans le travail n'ont pas la
possibilité de rencontrer d'autres
personnes se sont débordés ouverte en
mai puis pas l'environnement non plus et
c'est tous les milieux sociaux
d'ailleurs c'était fini et c'est
absolument tous les maux sociaux qui
sont qui sont concernés on trouve tous
les milieux sociaux sur les réseaux
sociaux et il ya un brassage comme ça
avec oui voilà disons quand on arrive
sur un réseau sur un réseau social c'est
comme si on était en proie à une foule
c'est très compliqué de choisir les une
foule les autres c'est mal barré dans
une foule tout le monde ne vous plairait
pas non plus mais mais en moins quand
vous êtes dans une foule vous avez une
première impression qui est là
l'impression de visu parce qu'on dégage
quelque chose il ya pas seulement ce
qu'on dit il ya le langage infra verbal
ya la gestuelle ya tous ces lignes
accompagnent leur sensibilité et alors
quand quand on dépasse un peu le cadre
là de la première rencontre et que ça va
un peu plus loin
c'est à dire que le siec centre en jeu
est ce que il y a des différences entre
les hommes et les femmes finalement
est-ce que ce que les deux se disent las
que je vais être à la hauteur ou est-ce
que la question se pose pas
[Musique]
c'est un mec c'est un peu basique je
dirais pas ça
disons ça encore
disons que bon chasseur ce
livre c'est quand même une petite
compilation de tout ce que j'ai pu
entendre au sein de mon cabinet est sûr
aussi la libre antenne est aussi ce qui
s'est dit pendant quatre ans dans les
dents les thèmes qu'on a pu aborder mais
voilà en règle générale qu'on le veuille
ou non même si on dit que les hommes et
les femmes c'est pareil moi je constate
que dans la réalité au quotidien il ya
une différence la question première que
se pose un homme c'est vrai jettera la
hauteur donc il va raisonner en termes
de performances la vraie question
existentielle de l'homme c'est suis
capable d'avoir une érection et de la
tenir ça c'est pour le masculin la femme
elle l est dans un autre registre elle
est la peur de ne pas être à la hauteur
mais elle a peur de déplaire donc
la nudité c'est un moment particulier
pour une femme en tout cas les femmes
ont toujours été qu'on le veuille ou non
même si on s'en défend aujourd'hui élevé
avec un certain esprit de séduction donc
est-ce qu'elle va regarder en premier
c'est est-ce que je vais pleurer ce que
mon corps va lui plaire est ce que cet
homme là va me désiré est ce que tous
les défauts physiques les vergetures la
cellulite le petit bourrelet coget la
cicatrice et c est ce que c'est pas
est-ce que je ne suis pas du temps après
je ne sais même pas la cruauté de ce que
j'entends ouais je suis toujours frappé
par font éclater des du regard que les
femmes portent sur elles mêmes les
hommes pendant la grille au t1 pendant
la cruauté du regard que les femmes
portent sûr que je suis toujours
absolument sidéré il y en a pas une qui
se dit mon dieu quand je vais me
déshabiller il va être absolument ébloui
par la splendeur de leur passion nous
avons l'impression que les femmes qui
ont très sûre d'elle c'est pas forcément
le cas quoi ça veut dire que c'est un
point faible c'est une plus faible
proportion ouais ouais c'est quand même
une plus faible proportion les femmes se
trouveront tous les défauts de la terre
médaille hommes sont somptueuses c'est
amusant donne alors pour la première
fois qu'ils couchent ensemble je défie
en gros
ils rêvaient enfin pouvoir tenir un peu
plus longtemps alors miss culpabilise de
ça et elle elle se culpabiliser aussi
c'est ça c'est ça c'est intéressant un
dixième à à se faire c'est
peut-être de ma faute est ce que c'est
moi qui suscite ça et puis elle choisit
si vous avez du livre de terminer sur
une note plus de petits bruits sonores
il ya évidemment on n'a pas déflorer
tout en disant qu'ils vont se rencontrer
parce que voilà
avant évidemment il ya d'autres
rencontres et ça c'est une partie très
amusant et très vrai je pensais très
amusant de votre roman
ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure c'est que
évidemment sur les réseaux sociaux sur
les sites de rencontre on essaye de
donner le meilleur de soi même mais
parfois il ya naturel revient au galop
alors il ya par exemple le radin le
radar alors ils plient chipote parce que
là la réduction de 2 euros qu'on avait
faits sur la formule quand il invite
génie à dîner bon on l'a pas fait ils
devraient se dire comme le mec la
première fois tant pis hybris alors ça
lui fait de mal de payer deux euros de
cachet banon c'est 100 km pour venir en
plus oui
oui ça va ça va te coûter tour descend
ça c'est marrant parce que skd des
défauts comme ça qu'il faut que le
naturel revient au galop on peut pas le
cacher quoi
là pour le coup c'est pas de la fiction
c'est quelqu'un qui me l'a réellement
racontez en créant ce donc je ne vois là
je n'en dirai pas plus mais c'est ça
du tout
mais
c'est arrivé c'est à dire que l'aura
d'un de toute façon il est dans un état
de défunts et les descentes il est dans
un état psychique tels que il fait les
comptes tout le temps ce que c'est lui
coûte et c'est plus une question
d'identité c'est à dire qu'il peut pas
lâcher comme
s'est expliqué
il peut pas lâcher c'est identitaire
c'est à dire que si ce qu on lui on lui
prend de lui vous laisser comme ça lui
sert et ça lui prend de lui et c'est
trop la la la la prise est trop
importante en fait ça serait trop donner
voilà donc il ya le radin mais il n'ya
pas que lui non non il
ya aussi moi je pensais y avait beaucoup
de deux garçons plutôt calé sur les sur
les sites de rencontres pour avoir une
aventure d'un soir et là vous montrer
c'est cette raison qui ça peut être
aussi des femmes layton qui a ses
sublimes
bas je veux juste de passer un bon
moment elle veut passer un bon moment il
y aura après le jeu toi moi ce qui
m'intéressait surtout de montrer dans ce
livre c'est à quel point les hommes sont
déstabilisés par cette attitude
féminines c'est à dire que on est
toujours à ce que ces mêmes intéressant
d'ailleurs de voir la question que vous
me posez parce que la question que vous
me posez c'est bien c'est dingue les
femmes font comme les hommes
et non pas des mêmes options et ça peut
arriver qu'il y ait envie seulement dans
désir sexuel d'un résident tueur et que
si la personne le parfum est pas mal en
face c'est bien elle va elles vont aussi
y aller complètement comme le frêle mais
ce qui est intéressant c'est de voir à
quel point même déstabilisé par cette
attitude là alors que eux ne font depuis
mais parce qu'on dise est souvent là la
grande différence entre les hommes et
les femmes c'est que les hommes font la
différence entre le sexe et le sentiment
alors que les femmes l'idée 2 bon c'est
pas ça a dû changer non seulement ça a
changé mais vous avez aussi des femmes
qui se protège de cette façon là c'est à
dire qu'elles ont besoin aussi
de tester leur pouvoir de séduction
mais par ailleurs elles ont beaucoup
souffert et elles n'ont pas envie non
plus de se retrouver je veux dire que
l'aventuré amoureuse et pour elle
synonyme de douleur donc elle préfère se
préserver et s'en tenir strictement à la
relation sexuelle qui ne les appliquent
pas plus que ça
oui parce que je trouvais aussi
intéressant dans votre vie c'est que
vous avez choisi de montrer de parler de
personnages qui sont assez banal et qui
qu'ils soient nés héros et on voit
qu'ils ont besoin de tout gérer en
permanence à dire qu'ils gèrent la
petite robe qu'elle va porter et dont on
va parler avec sa copine comme ils et
elles gèrent leurs enfants vers leurs
émotions gère toutes difficultés liées à
la l'imprévu alors moi je me suis
demandée finalement qu'est
l'apprentissage on parlait tout à
l'heure de l'apprentissage au bonheur et
peut-être aussi qu'est l'apprentissage
de la liberté
ça ce serait un bel apprentissage
et justement c'est j'ai voulu j'ai voulu
livrer des détails j'ai envie de dire
très prosaïque danse dans ce livre parce
que qu'est-ce que vous croyez que
j'entends toute la journée dans mon
cabinet et bien exactement ça c'est à
dire que ce sont des gens qui sont pris
par tous les détails du quotidien et
toute la gestion du quotidien on ne veut
pas vous prouvez moi contrôlent aussi
les sentiments comme on gère
zizou tenir dans votre livre fait que
non ça vient maintenant chez axa vient
de l'apprentissage ça vient de l'enfance
ase vient surtout de ceux précisément ce
qu'on leur a transmis il est beaucoup
question de transmission
il est beaucoup question de transmission
parce que on a tendance à répéter il ya
une très jolie phrase qui dit la vie
vous sert toujours le même plat jusqu'à
ce qu'on comprenne ce qu'on mange c'est
exactement ça c'est à dire qu'on va
répéter on va gérer sans s'interroger
même sur le sens et la signification de
ce qu'on est en train de faire et ce qui
est intéressant c'est de se pencher sur
pourquoi j'ai fait ça
pourquoi j'ai fait ça pourquoi j'ai agi
de telle manière pourquoi j'ai besoin de
confier les enfants pourquoi est-ce que
j'ai besoin de courir acheter le cadeau
est d'être par exemple on vous parliez
tout à l'heure de l'injonction au
bonheur mais il ya l'injonction aussi à
être un parent parfait y consent siens à
la parentalité d'ailleurs et d'ailleurs
les deux bulles pas billy's un peu quand
ils vont rencontrer quelqu'un d'autre
parce que jusque là ils ont en gros
élevés avec avec le lot l'autre l'autre
parent enfin élevé seuls leurs enfants
et puis tout d'un coup il va falloir
présentait la fille
nouveau mec ou les garçons à la nouvelle
heure écoutez sur c'est quoi ouais si
vous voulez dans ce livre en fait ce que
je voulais c'était explorer un certain
nombre de deux scènes auxquelles on va
tous être confrontés on a tous envie
d'être un moment on a tous envie que ce
afin de rencontrer et que ça fonctionne
et il ya un certain nombre j'ai envie de
dire de fondamentaux auxquels ofas
confrontés c'est à dire les parents les
enfants quand on en a pas ce qu on a 40
ans et on a déjà eu une vie avant les ex
les a ni la belle famille le travail et
comment on fait comment s'inscrit la
rencontre l'album voilà et c'était
l'occasion en tant que psy c'est pour ça
que c'est une fiction parce que je
trouvais que c'était plus facile de
donner quelques clés comme ça parce
qu'on peut s'identifier
plutôt qu'un livre où on donne les
recettes de l'origine je trouve
excellent évidemment qu'on peut
identifier cette affaire personnelle là
c'était plus facile de donner quelques
clés et de rappeler comme ça quelques
quelques fondamentaux simple presque de
bon sens auquel mais qu'on doit avoir
inscrit et ne pas se laisser justement
débordé par toute cette gestion dont
vous parlez il ya une question que tout
ça pose parce que évidemment s'il ya les
réseaux via les réseaux sociaux il ya
les sites de rencontre il ya une façon
de gérer
l'amour qui est qui qui est très
différente et puis mais finalement il ya
comme le couple qui reste est ce que est
ce que on est dans une société qui
évolue énormément ou la procréation et
et la sexualité sont séparés mais est ce
que je sais pas c'est une question de
vagues je vous demander ce que vous
pensez que le couple va rester ou que
c'est une structure qui pourrait éclater
écoutez moi ce que je constate tous les
jours dans mon cabinet c'est que on n'a
qu'une seule envie c'est d'être aimé
aider mais voilà c'est que je crois que
peut-être quand vous la grande affaire
de la vie passée voilà je pense que
depuis la minute où on est on est tous
en trois sets angoisses existentielles
de mort et que la seule façon qu'ont
trouvé les hommes et femmes de la
contrée c'est précisément l'amour donc
qui dit amour dit forcément couple ce
qu'on ne fait pas assez si aujourd'hui
le couffin on constate que le couple
éternelle comme celui des générations
d'entendre ça on le sait il va pas durer
autant mais en tout cas l'idée c'est
toujours de faire couple de fer et ben
voila je lui dise unis
l'histoire double c'est donc c'est anne
carrière c'est un roman de caroline
vague merci infiniment merci à nos
conseils évidemment ça raconter
d'histoire d'abord une histoire très
touchantes comme vous le disiez qui est
très proche de la réalité et puis et
puis on peut y trouver comme vous disiez
déconseille aussi si j'avais alors c'est
elle rentrait sur voix sur les réseaux
sociaux donc il ya les deux aspects qui
sont qui sont tout à fait passionnant
merci beaucoup merci michel 6
[Musique]